thank you very much our nation is
engaged in a historic battle against the
invisible enemy to win this fight we
have undertaken the greatest national
mobilization since World War two and
that's exactly what it's been
we've marshaled every instrument of
American power and we've unleashed our
most potent weapon of all the courage of
the American people
these have been trying times a cruel
virus from a distant land has unfairly
claimed thousands of precious American
lives to every citizen who has lost a
cherished loved one your pain is our
pain we mourn as one National family our
country has come together we draw a
solace from the faith that God has
received and the departed he has taken
the departed into his eternal and loving
embrace they will never be forgotten
over the last weeks and months millions
of Americans have joined together in a
shared national sacrifice to halt the
spread of this horrible disease the army
built field hospitals and sports arenas
and convention centers the Army Corps of
Engineers is great over twenty thousand
beds in record time
the Navy sailed hospital ships to our
biggest cities life-saving supplies and
experimental medicines were rushed to
the frontlines as we launched a rapid
search for groundbreaking treatments and
vaccines we built the most advanced and
robust testing anywhere in the world and
we've done more testing than any country
anywhere in the world we suspended
dangerous foreign travel we leveraged
our industrial base to produce vast
quantities of critical medical gear and
enacted a historic two trillion dollar
relief package through it all we have
seen the heroism of our doctors and
nurses like never before these are our
warriors the bravery of our truck
drivers such bravery and food suppliers
such incredible bravery and the
determination and drive of our citizens
through this unified national endeavor
we have made great progress you could
really say incredible progress our
experts and scientists report that our
strategy to slow the spread has saved
hundreds of thousands of lives models
predicted between 1.5 million and 2.2
million u.s. deaths if there was no
mitigation it could have even been
higher than that and between 100,000 and
240,000 deaths with mitigation it's
looking like we will come far under even
these lowest numbers thanks to our
all-out military operation and the
extraordinary devotion of our people we
believe we will experience far fewer
deaths then even the optimistic
projection but there is no such thing as
an optimistic projection on death one
person is too many our experts say the
curve has flattened and the peak in new
cases is behind us nationwide more than
850 counties or nearly 30% of our
country have reported no new cases in
the last seven days because of our early
and aggressive action we have avoided
the tragedy of health care rationing and
deadly shortfalls that have befallen
many other
Asians nations which wherever possible
we are helping in America no person who
was needed a ventilator has been denied
a ventilator for making hundreds of
thousands of ventilators we've delivered
thousands and thousands of ventilators
to the states and actually it's been an
incredible operation we started with
very little and we ended with a lot the
United States has achieved a significant
lower mortality rate then almost all
other countries based on the latest data
our team of experts now agrees that we
can begin the next front in our war
which we are calling opening up America
again and that's what we're doing we're
opening up our country and we have to do
that America wants to be open and
Americans want to be open as I have said
for some time now a national shutdown is
not a sustainable long-term solution to
preserve the health of our citizens we
must also preserve the health and
functioning of our economy over the long
haul you can't do one without the other
cannot be done to keep vital supply
chains earning these chains have to be
taken care of so delicately they're
delicate the balance is delicate we want
to deliver food and medical supply we
must have a working economy and we want
to get it back very very quickly and
that's what's going to happen I believe
it will boom a prolonged lockdown
combined with a forced economic
depression would inflict an immense and
wide-ranging toll on public health this
includes a sharp rise in drug abuse
alcohol abuse suicide heart disease
and many other dimensions of physical
and mental well-being moreover many
patients have put needed medical care on
hold creating entirely new hazards for
public health our country has suffered
the world has suffered one hundred and
eighty four other countries have
suffered therefore my administration is
issuing new federal guidelines that will
allow governor's to take a phased and
deliberate approach to reopening their
individual states I've dealt with them
now a long time and we've had a great
relationship democrat-republican the
relationship has been good this strategy
is based on hard verifiable data I want
to thank dr. Burks for her incredible
leadership in crafting these guidelines
in consultation with scientists experts
and medical professionals across
government dr. Burks will explain the
guidelines in more detail in a few
moments and dr. Fuji has been absolutely
terrific we've all worked together and
we've worked together well they are
interested in the health of our country
and we're all interested in the
viability and making us truly great
again we took the greatest economy in
the history of the world and we closed
it in order to win this war and we're in
the process of winning it now our
approach outlines three phases in
restoring our economic life
we are not opening all at once but one
careful step at a time and some states
will be able to open up sooner than
others some states are not in the kind
of trouble that others are in now that
we have passed the peek in new cases
we're starting our life again we're
starting rejuvenation
of our economy again in a safe and
structured and very responsible fashion
our strategy will continue to protect
senior citizens and other vulnerable
populations while allowing military and
other groups of incredibly talented
people to go about their real business
and the business that's supposed to be
hard at work at doing and nobody does it
better our military is the greatest
anywhere in the world and we're so
thankful for what they've done
healthy Americans will now be able to
return to work as conditions on the
ground allow instead of a blanket
shutdown we will pursue a focus on
sheltering the highest risk individuals
so important we're establishing clear
scientific metric and benchmarks on
testing new case growth and hospital
capacity that must be met before
advancing to each phase and that's each
phase specifically in the reopening of
our country this is a gradual process as
the caseload in a state continues to go
down restrictions can continue to be
eased and come off throughout the
process citizens will continue to be
called upon to use all of their weapons
in this war vigorous hygiene teleworking
when possible staying at home if you
feel sick maintaining social distance
sanitizing commonly used surfaces and
being highly conscious of their
surroundings those are our weapons and
they're very powerful weapons indeed
governor's will be empowered to tailor
an approach that meets the diverse
circumstances of their own States every
state is very different they're all
beautiful we love them all but they're
very very different if they need to
remain closed we will allow them to do
that and if they believe it is time to
reopen
we will provide them the freedom and
guidance to accomplish that task and
very very quickly depending on what they
want to do we are also encouraging
States to work together to harmonize
their regional efforts we'll have
numerous cases where states have worked
and will be working very very closely
together as we reopen we know that there
will be continued hardships and
challenges ahead our goal will be to
quickly identify and address any
outbreaks and put them out rapidly if
the virus returns in the fall as some
scientists think it may possibly these
guidelines will ensure that our country
is up and running so that we can
likewise put it out quickly at the heart
of our strategy is the vital role of
medical research especially for
therapies that will significantly
improve outcomes for high-risk patients
and reduce the need for urgent care this
will be tremendously valuable in
allowing life to eventually return to
normal at least 35 clinical trials are
already underway including antiviral
therapies immune therapies and blood
therapies in the form of convalescent
plasma you've all heard about some of
these events and some of these therapies
they've come a long way what's been done
in the last four weeks is incredible we
will also continue to expand our testing
capacity we have now completed more than
3.5 million tests by far the most
anywhere in the world areas of our
country that have been hotspots have
done much more testing on a per capita
basis then South Korea we've done more
than South Korea and South Korea has
done a good job but we've done more we
will continue to work with governor's to
advise them on
how to conduct both surveillance and
diagnostic testing we have now
distributed over 600,000 Abbot ID now
point-of-care diagnostic tests these are
tests that are done on-site and within
five minutes you know the answer
positive or negative in recent days we
have seen a dramatic increase in the
number of tests performed by hospitals
and academic institutions with more than
120 thousand tests recently reported in
a single day far more than any country
in the world has ever been able to do
and our numbers are actually going up as
these new and better testing solutions
come online we're seeing this additional
capacity reflected in the numbers for
this reason the number of tests
processed in commercial laboratories has
dropped from approximately 100,000 to
roughly 75,000 tests over the last week
the reason it dropped is because we have
so many other tests and we don't even
have to go through the laboratories but
the laboratories have tremendous
additional capacity and states feel free
to use that capacity some in the media
falsely reported this as a bad thing
when in fact it is a great thing because
it indicates that the states are moving
to faster more local testing solutions
including on-the-spot tests so this drop
in the utilization of commercial
laboratories is an affirmation that
testing which is at an all-time high is
growing at a historic rate in other
words the laboratories are great but now
we have forms of testing that are much
quicker much better and we don't have to
use the laboratories but they're there
and they have a great capacity to do the
work as dr. Burks has been advising our
governors for weeks we continue to have
an excess testing capacity of 1 million
tests
per week available for use and our
capabilities are growing every single
day especially with the new tests that
are coming onto the market rapidly as we
begin a science-based reopening we must
be extra vigilant in blocking the
foreign entry of the virus from abroad
border control travel restrictions and
other limitations on entry are more
important than ever to keep the virus in
check and allow Americans to get back to
work the sacrifices our citizens have
made and this time of crisis will be
remembered studied honored and praised
for generations to come
we're really all working together
Democrat Republican conservative liberal
we're all working together this is not
about parties this is about our country
now the American people are ready to
rise to the occasion once again they are
ready to show the world once more that
Americans can defeat any Challenger
together we will rebuild this land that
we love we will reclaim the Magnificent
destiny that we share and we will carry
our nation forward to new heights of
greatness and glory I would now like to
ask vice president Mike Pence and dr.
Burks to further explain the new
guidelines I want to thank dr. Burks I
want to thank dr. pouchy and I want to
thank really especially a man who has
devoted 24 hours a day to his task force
and done such an incredible job our a
great vice president Mike Pence please
Mike
Thank You mr. president the members of
the White House coronavirus task force
today joined the president to meet with
bipartisan group of members of the house
and of the Senate to get their counsel
on the development of what the president
unveiled to America's governors this
afternoon the new guidelines for opening
up America again are a product of the
best science and the best common-sense
that the president has marshaled on this
team and from a broad range of advisors
from all across the nation from the
moment president Trump established the
White House coronavirus Task Force
early on he made it clear that that we
have no higher priority than the health
and safety of the American people the
president launched a whole-of-government
approach and while we stand here on this
day with more than 640,000 Americans
having contracted to coronavirus and our
hearts go out to the families of the
more than 31,000 Americans who lost
their lives and and those who continue
to struggle with serious consequences of
the coronavirus the truth is that
because of the decisive action that our
president took early on suspending
travel from China and thereafter from
portions of Europe and South Korea
screening passengers because of the
strong actions in partnership with every
governor across America because of the
extraordinary efforts of America's
health care workers on the front lines
and because of the cooperation of the
American people and God's grace we are
slowing the spread we are flattening the
curve we have preserved the capacity of
our health care system and we've
protected the most vulnerable in a word
because of the actions of this president
this administration governors at every
level or health care workers and our
fellow Americans we've saved lives
and every American should be comforted
by that and we can see it in the numbers
in the charts that I'll present today
these three maps track influenza-like
illness which in this instance is mostly
coronavirus across America the first map
reflects the total number of cases on
the week ending March the 28th the next
map reflects our data about the total
number of cases on the week ending April
4th and we stand here today with the
final map reflecting the total number of
cases across America as of April the
11th with these trends underway
President Trump has the White House
coronavirus task force to develop new
guidelines for opening up America again
those guidelines were presented today
first to our nation's governors and it
is our intention at the president's
direction to provide these guidelines to
assist governors and state health
officials in evaluating the most
responsible manner to reopen the
economies of their states at a time and
manner of their choosing the guidelines
as Americans who are looking on will
note begin with what is the best
criteria that our experts have developed
a downward trajectory in cases over a 14
day period of time ensuring that states
have proper capacity in their health
care facilities the second set of
proposals includes a description of
recommendations for state preparedness
and let me say to the American people
what President Trump made clear to our
governors today that our administration
will continue to work day in and day out
through our task force through FEMA to
ensure that our states have not only the
medical supplies but that we continue to
rapidly expand testing across the nation
the president reflected on the progress
we've made on testing but a few
statistics for that as well which I hope
are an encouragement to the American
people on March 11th we had performed at
O
of 20 3588 tests because of the
public-private partnership the president
Trump initiated with commercial labs
across the country that number was
eighty three thousand five hundred by
March 18th and as the president just
said that number is three point five
million today it is our expectation that
we will have tested more than five
million Americans before the end of the
month of April and will continue to
scale those resources so testing and
medical supplies will continue to be an
ongoing partnership with our states and
we want our health care workers and
people all across the country to know of
our commitment to that finally the
president has directed us to propose a
phased approach to reopening to
reopening our economy it is based on
up-to-date data and readiness and will
continue to provide the very best data
to our state's working with their health
officials the focus is on the mitigation
of any risk of resurgence or the
emergence of the corona virus in states
where it's not yet emerged there is a
focus in the president's new guidelines
on the most vulnerable and it's we made
this very clear to the governor's today
these new guidelines for opening up
America again can be implemented on a
statewide basis or on a county-by-county
basis with that I'm happy to turn it
over to dr. deborah birx and if I may
mr. president I'd like to also extend my
admiration and appreciation to dr. Burks
dr. Fauci and every member of our task
force that worked around the clock to
develop these recommendations for
opening up America well I know every
American is grateful for your leadership
and for theirs Thank You mr. president
mr. vice president we're gonna go
through these quickly cuz I know you
have them and many of you have already
spoken to them on television next slide
please
this is a very important slide it talks
about the gatekeeping on the gatekeeping
criteria to moving into phase one it's
very much related to what you just saw
about influenza like illness and the
United States has been tracking
influenza like illness through the
Centers of the disease control for years
both the state and public health
officials are used to watching this
County health officials are used to
watching it and frankly every family
around the United States knows how to
access this on the CDC website in order
to get updated up to date information to
the communities it also looks at a
cinder ohmic emergency room type visits
again housed at the CDC and really is
our surveillance program that can be
utilized for a lot of different
illnesses but in this case will be
utilized for respiratory diseases in
addition we are tracking the number of
cases and it must have a downward
trajectory for 14 days as well as the
influenza like illness and the syndromic
illnesses and a downward trajectory in
the number of positive tests with
persistence of high levels of testing
for the hospitals its interests to
ensure that we can treat all patients
without resorting to any crisis care and
ensuring that there's a robust testing
program in place for at-risk health care
workers including frontlines responders
with the emerging antibody test next
slide just to show you what this looks
like so what the CDC did for me under
the direction of Bob Redfield was to
chart what would the syndromic illnesses
were reporting throughout the early part
of March and you can see in New Orleans
respiratory diseases were starting to be
seen in the emergency room that is the
red line the cases are shown in the dark
blue line the gray Mountain is testing
and underneath that is the blue mountain
of positives and you can see that the
early alert was present
from the emergency room about early
respiratory disease you can see it
predated the cases so throughout the
summer when we do not have flu to
contaminate this picture we'll be able
to follow the syndromic pattern city by
city county by county community by
community state by state next slide in
addition the CDC has the influenza-like
illness net distributed throughout the
United States very useful in the
wintertime that first peak is influenza
B in the red that's the season I showed
you all the seasons here so you could
see the seasons as they are displayed
the first peak is influenza B second
peak in xoans influenza A and then you
can see the corona virus and you can see
its decline and it's declining towards
baseline this will allow us again city
by city community by community state by
state to look for variations in an early
response mode in those at localities
that I described next slide so hopefully
you see that we've brought CDC and their
amazing talent of individuals at the
Center for Disease Control and
Prevention and all of their abilities to
this response and also to the
surveillance that we need in this
response but I want to call your
attention to the third bullet on this
graphic so we're tracking those two
pieces that I described but the third
bullet is about setting up Sentinel
surveillance sites to be able to
distinguish and find asymptomatic
individuals individuals that you have
heard about that may be either pre
symptomatic or asymptomatic throughout
their entire disease course we want to
be able to find them in communities of
particular vulnerability so we'll be
doing sentinel surveillance throughout
nursing homes throughout inner-city
federal clinics throughout indigenous
populations to really be able to find
early alerts of asymptomatic individuals
in the community and both for the sender
ohmic cases that are tested the flu
influenza-like cases and the
symptomatic cases doing contact tracing
again with support from the Centers for
Disease Control working without each
state and local government in addition
we want to make sure that all the health
care facilities have adequate protective
personal protective devices and the
equipment to handle the surge and to
ensure the ICUs
can handle increased capacity we want
every state to have a plan for the
health and safety of its workers in
critical industries and to protect the
health and Safety's of those living in
high-risk facilities including senior
care facilities as we discussed with
Sentinel surveillance but also
additional surveillance when we talked
with all of the states that had not had
a major Metro outbreak their sentinels
surveillances picked up always the first
cases in nursing homes and so this is a
very much a big focus of the plan moving
forward I won't go into the rest of the
details on this slide but there's quite
a bit of details on the expectations of
every state and local government next
slide you'll recognize this slide it's a
next slide please
you'll recognize this slide is what
we've been talking about in the 15 and
30 days to prevent the spread it's
continuing those in critical
hand-washing or sanitizer is not
avoiding touching your face at all times
disinfecting surfaces using face
covering while in public following state
local guidelines and critically staying
home if you are sick I know a lot of
people go to the workplace when they are
feeling ill you know when you're feeling
ill it won't get better by going to work
so we're asking again for people to stay
home when they're sick next slide is for
employers to ensure that there can be
social distancing and a protective
equipment their temperature checks use
of disinfectant in high-traffic areas
including break rooms and assuring that
we don't do I said there's no
non-essential business travel and then
monitoring for any symptomatic
individuals in the workplace and again
if you come become ill at work to
immediately to go home and ensure that
there's content
tracing of all the individuals that
become sick I'm gonna go through the
phases very quickly but you have the
details phase one again you have to go
through those gating criterias related
to 14 days of decreasing evidence of
illness and decreasing testing despite
adequate testing so phase one begins
with all vulnerable individuals
including those with comorbidities
continuing to shelter in place and
ensuring that those that first go out
into the public are not those that are
most vulnerable to bad outcomes in this
disease and then ensuring that we
continue to do six feet maximum physical
distancing in public spaces continuing
to avoid large gatherings and all
non-essential travel for the employers
next slide again if a vulnerable
population needs to return to work and
cannot be teller working there should be
special accommodations for all
vulnerable populations as well as
options for teller working we believe
every employee should encourage work
return in phases from 20% or 25% to 40%
to 50% and again minimize all
non-essential travel phase 1 continued
next slide if the schools are already
closed they should remain closed all
visits to senior living facilities and
hospitals should be continue to be
prohibited large venues including
sit-down dining can only be operated
under strict physical distancing
protocols and maintaining those six feet
gyms could open if they have again could
here too strict physical distancing and
elective surgeries can resume on an
outpatient basis Phase two next slide
next slide again you have to go through
the criteria again of a continuation of
another 14-day decline among those
criterias that were in the gating again
we're asking for all vulnerable
individuals shelter in place we did not
put a timeline on any of the phases we
want the governor's with the data that
they have community by community to be
setting up those timelines
again we're asking for the public to
continue to maximize physical distance
however we increased social settings to
be able to now have 50 individuals and
non-essential travel can resume next
slide this is for the employers we still
would like to encourage telework and the
common common area should remain closed
or be physically distance all
non-essential travel for employees can
can resume and then again special
accommodations for vulnerable next slide
this should be a relief to many of
households that have small children
schools daycares and camps can reopen in
Phase two visits a senior living
facilities however should remain and
hospitals prohibited large venues can
operate but slowly under moderate
physical distancing and elective
surgeries can resume on an outpatient
and inpatient basis Phase three and so
phase three I won't go through in detail
which is essentially returning to our
new normal with all of the what we
talked about through all phases
continuing the good hygiene practices
continuing their respect for spaces
between individuals because we know that
we still have an issue with a
symptomatic spread I do believe with
this plan that we're both confronting
the issue of finding symptomatic
individuals through our networks with
early alert as well as those who come
and present to different hospitals an
emergency room with testing and contact
tracing but critically have put in place
what we believe is a safety net through
asymptomatic sentinel surveillance that
is centered around our most vulnerable
groups between nursing homes and native
are a Native American people and
indigenous populations and our
inner-city groups that we know maybe in
multi-generational households and have
unique risk I'll stop there mr.
president
thank you very much mr. president mr.
vice president so as you've seen just
now from the detailed presentation from
dr. Burks this is a rather robust
program for re-entering into normality
there's a lot of details here and I know
it'll take a little bit time to digest
them all so what I thought would be good
since I really want to be brief to allow
time for questions is to kind of take us
back to the discussions that we've had
here before and why this is a natural
evolution from what we had said before
you might recall that on a few occasions
when I was up here before you I told you
that when we get to the point we're
gonna take those steps towards trying to
get back to some form of normality that
it would not be a light switch that you
could turn on and off I meant that in
two different components the first of
all that we are a very large country and
we have different dynamics in the
country we have areas of the country
that have gone through a terrible ordeal
and others that fortunately have gone
and gotten gotten through this rather
lightly so that's the first thing the
second thing is that our light switch on
and off is the exact opposite of what
you see here which is a gradual relation
with the first thing and the only thing
in mind as the health people here my
colleagues who are either physicians
scientists or public health issues the
predominant and completely driving
element that we put into this was the
safety and the health of the American
public and I know there are a lot of
other considerations that go into
opening considerations that you've heard
of right from this podium but the
dominating drive of this was to make
sure that this is done in the safest way
possible so let me just make a couple of
comments to just reiterate more from a
broader standpoint the things that dr.
Burks did so well in in a very granular
detail first of all in order to even
consider getting into the phasing
you have to pay us a hurdle and that's
the hurdle that we refer to as gating in
now when you think about it and look at
the map of the country and look at the
differences in different parts of the
country you will see that there are some
regions States locations that are going
to be almost already into some of that
gating and will have already fulfilled
some of those criteria others because of
the dynamics of the outbreak in the area
will take longer to be able to do that
but you don't get to Phase one until you
get through the gating and then in order
to make sure that safety and health is
the dominant issue the design of the
phases were just that you go into phase
one if you get no rebound and you
satisfy the gating but yet again a
second time then you go to Phase two if
you have no rebound and you satisfy the
gating criteria for a third time you go
into Phase three so there are multiple
checkpoints of safety there so as I've
said from this podium when we were
talking about the first 15 days of the
mitigation and then we extended it in
other 30 days I essentially pleaded with
the American public to say let us make
sure we do the best that we can to
accomplish that and in fact mitigation
works you saw the charts that the Vice
President and that doctor Bert's put up
it worked and what we hope and I believe
we will be successful if we carefully do
this again with the attention to the
safety and health of the American public
that we will be able to it will be
staggered not every state not every
region is going to do it at the same
time that's clearly obvious because of
the very dynamics of the outbreak but we
feel confident that sooner or later we
will get to the point hopefully sooner
with safety as the most important thing
to a point where we can be get back to
some form of normality the one thing I
liked about it that that dr. Berg said
so well is that no matter what phase
you're in there are certain fundamental
things that we
done that are not like it was in
September in October you want to call it
the new normal you can call it whatever
you want but even if you are in phase 1
2 3 it's not ok
game over it's not it's gonna be a way
that we protect ourselves because as we
know and as I've said from this podium
it may very well be as we go the cycle
around that there'll be this virus that
wants to come back to us I think we're
gonna be able to handle that thank you
so I assume that there's an also a phase
4 which is after a vaccine is developed
and available to everybody so question
on phase 3 being the new normal are we
during that phase gonna be able to see
things like packed arenas for sporting
events large crowds concerts the answer
is it is conceivable that we will be
able to do that I think there will
always have to be attention to making
sure that we don't do all that packing
in together I think we'll be able to
have sports events in that phase where
you actually have participants there I'm
not sure you're gonna be able to do that
uniformly and evenly temporally with
everyone but when people get to that
phase paying attention to the fact that
if there is a rebound of any sort that
when you're in that phase you can
respond to that or you've put it back
and go in the other way so the
flexibility is that there may be some
setbacks I mean let's face it this this
is uncharted water there may be some
setbacks that we may have to pull back a
little and then go forward but John the
direct answer to your question I do see
us getting more towards normal if you
take a look at the dating criteria is
that lying in these guidelines that are
there are at least a handful of states
I've slipped into trendline
Idaho Wyoming Hawaii Montana they look
like they've already satisfied that
bathing criteria in your coal with the
governor's this afternoon did you hear
back from any states who said we're
already there we could start the process
again from a number of governor's that
said they're in very good shape I also
heard not only from the coal but I heard
from some of the governor's previous and
I think you have some very good things
to report over the next few days about
States opening up and I think John
having to do with you call on on sports
depending on the area depending what
we're talking about you're gonna have
large areas of our country where this
has not been or has been totally
eradicated you'll be able to have those
fill arenas now with everything being
said a lot of great work has been done
on vaccines but you have a testing
process therapeutics likewise we have a
lot of great things happening
therapeutically that will be a step
further but in terms of sports they'll
probably start off I as you know I spoke
to the commissioners yesterday almost I
guess of every sport and many of them
are going to be starting with out the
fans so it'll be made-for-television the
good old days made for television and
it'll go that way and then fans will
start coming in maybe they'll be
separated by two seats and then
ultimately we want to have packed arenas
when the virus is gone we're going to
have packed arenas and we're going to be
back to enjoying sports the way they're
supposed to be and the same thing can be
said for restaurants so at a certain
point in time when the virus is gone
we're gonna be back to normal please mr.
president and the doctors can you
clarify then it's the 30-day period to
stop the spread on those mitigation
efforts still in place or have they been
replaced by this new guidance well
they're going to be in place to a large
extent and it also depends on the
governor's what they want to do you have
very different states if you look at
Montana Wyoming North Dakota that's a
lot different than New York it's a lot
different than New Jersey so it's going
to be very dependent on the governor and
we're recommending as you see in the
charts we're recommending certain things
they'll be in place dependent on what
the
wants to do if we see something wrong we
will be expressing ourselves very
strongly
Thank You mr. president does this mean
that states such as Montana and Utah
that already meet that gating period
will they be able to go to phase one is
early as sane tomorrow if the governor
decides you're talking about those
states that are in great shape already
they will be able to go literally
tomorrow yes because they've met all of
the guidelines if you go back you're
going back 14 days you're going back
even a month and they have the ones that
I'm thinking about the ones that I've
already spoken to governor's about
they've met those guidelines actually
pretty long ago what's your message to
the protesters we see we saw a lot of
Michigan but in other schools that are
saying that they are refusing to comply
with the stay at home orders issued by
governors and local officials I mean
isn't it important for everybody to go
along with this as we go through these
phases well they've been going through
it a long time John and it's been a
tough process for people you know I told
you this there's death and there's
problems and staying at home too it's
not just isn't it wonderful to stay at
home they're having this suffering that
this country wasn't built on that
principle it was built on an exact
opposite principle actually and I
watched in one particular state where
they were they want to get back they
want to get back they were very strict
sanctions that were put on people that
was probably the most strict of all but
I just think the American people have
been incredible when you look at John
when you look at what they've done when
you look at what they've been through
when you look at all of the death and
all of the problems and all of the
sickness when you look at what's
happened I just think the American
people have been incredible those
protestors to listen to local
authorities I think they're listening I
think they listen to me they seem to be
protesters that like me and respect this
opinion and my opinion is the same as
just about all of the governors they all
want to open nobody wants to say [ __ ]
but they want to open safely so do i but
we have large sections of the country
right now they can start thinking about
opening there'll be some mitigation and
they'll keep it going for a period
time including masks by the way in areas
that you wouldn't even think I asked a
question today I said why would they
wear masks in Wyoming or Montana or
North Dakota and that's if somebody
should come in from an area that isn't
so successful in terms of what they have
done so that will be a governor's choice
and we'll have no problem with it
mr. president you spoke this afternoon
with your new congressional advisory
groups 32 bipartisan members of the
House 65 bipartisan members of the
Senate one of the big topics which the
fact that the Small Business Association
long pot of 350 million dollars has hit
the cap it's exhausted there's nothing
moving on the 250 billion dollars to
replenish it what did you tell those
bipartisan groups today about getting
the move on to get some more money into
the hands of small business so just for
the viewers watching this or hearing you
ask that question exhausted is a good
thing not a bad thing it went quickly it
is so popular the banks have been
incredible including 4,000 community
banks 4,000 most people didn't know you
had that many banks for thousands no
need alone what they want is people want
to keep this going and we're doing it to
keep the small businesses open and to
keep the workers paid and we have two
hundred and fifty billion dollar
requests the Democrats like it the
Republicans love it and to be honest I
think it's going to something's going to
be happening I hope so because this is a
very popular program it was really
executed flawlessly the first day they
changed an application a little bit
there was a but when you look at what
Bank of America did and what Wells Fargo
did and City and a lot of the banks but
when you ask when you look at what all
of the community banks did it's been
really incredible well we're negotiating
with Democrats and they should frankly
approve it quickly there's a great thing
for our country it's a great thing for
small business and for the workers and
we're having a hard time getting them to
approve it I think it's going to happen
it should happen really unanimously but
they're trying to get things and we're
not too happy with what they're trying
to get placed on
first could you just say which states
specifically you guys think of hit the
gating requirements rather that say that
but you'll be seeing it very soon I mean
there'll be I'd rather have the governor
being able the governor's be able to
announce and they're very proud of it do
they work towards some are in an area
that's less susceptible and some really
was done I think we can say through
talent they really worked very hard and
you know we have some states that got
too much credit for what they've done
frankly I could name you a couple of
those too and I could name you a couple
of them and we have others that haven't
been given credit that have done a
phenomenal job part of the guidance
seems to sort of shift to States and
companies the burden not just of
additional testing and surveillance but
also this sort of new normal in which
you know there's smaller crowds and
restaurants and bars and normal there's
not going to be a new normal where
somebody has been having for twenty five
years a hundred and fifty eight seats in
a restaurant
and now he's got thirty where he's got
sixty because that wouldn't work that's
not normal no normal will be if he has
the 158 or 68 seats and that's going to
happen and it's gonna happen relatively
quickly we hope but that's our normal or
normal is if you have a hundred thousand
people in an Alabama football game or a
hundred and ten thousand to be exact we
want a hundred and ten thousand people
that we want every seat occupied normal
is not going to be where you have a game
with fifty thousand people to that point
I mean best-case scenario that happens
in the states are doing really well in a
month
obviously for I think a lot of other
states it's going to be longer than that
so my question is what is the federal
government going to do to sort of help
especially companies with states and
local governments in those positions pay
for what is now going to be an even
longer it standard we're going to be
watching over we're gonna see that
everything is working out smoothly we're
in very strong communication with the
governor's we're going to be helping
with testing they're going to be doing
the testing it's got to be a localized
thing and it really has been since I've
been involved because I came in and
federal government's supposed to do
testing of parking lots in the middle of
a certain state that's 2,000 miles away
it's ridiculous
but the testing has been so incredible
two things testing and ventilators
ventilators are really tough
they have very complex they're very
expensive they're you know very
sophisticated machines some are
unbelievably sophisticated well we built
you saw General Motors yesterday
thousands are being issued we have 11
companies building them we have not had
one complaint in the last week and half
which is surge time don't forget when
they were calling they will call him
because in two weeks and four weeks and
five weeks they're going to need
mentalize not because they need them
right now and we were right on our
counts and nobody that wanted a
ventilator didn't get a ventilator plus
we have additional if there is a surge
we hope there's not going to be a surge
at all but we're gonna be able to build
up the stockpiles of states who didn't
have them who should have had them and
we're also going to have a big stockpile
in the federal government and we'll be
able to help foreign countries countries
that need help because you have company
look you have countries we'll never be
able to build a ventilator it's tough
stuff we're uniquely talented in the
sense that we can do things that nobody
else can do we'll get it right back to
you
Peter in the back Peter thank you say
they were named the states that might be
right ready to go though can you give us
some more maybe the experts the dr.
Burke's and doctor foul should give us
some sense of how many yesterday you
said 29 states were in good shape you
think as many not yeah Peter I think 29
states are in that ballgame not open not
for opening but I think they'll be able
to open relatively soon I think the
remainder are just getting better look
New York New Jersey or having very tough
times and they'll be there they'll be
there at some point but they're not
going to be one of the earlier states
they're gonna be later obviously I just
spoke with the governor of New Jersey we
just spoke with Mike and a couple of
folks so we had a great talk with him
Phil is a terrific guy he's working very
hard Democrat but we get along he's
working very very hard I guess the fact
that he's right next to this big massive
city where everybody is very closely you
know that together and New Jersey's but
hit unbelief
Blee hard as hard as hard as anybody in
the true sense but they're doing a great
job in New Jersey that doesn't mean that
they're gonna be opening next week
that's not one that's going to be but we
have a lot of states that through
location through luck and also through a
lot of talent we have States through a
lot of talent are in a very good
position and they're getting ready to
open and over the next very short period
of time it's going to be up to the
governor's we're going to work with them
we're going to help them but it's going
to be up to the governors I think
they're going to I think you're gonna
see quite a few states starting to open
and I call it a beautiful puzzle you
have 50 pieces all very different but
when it's all done it's a mosaic when
it's all done it's gonna be a I think a
very beautiful picture and very
important is what doctor for out she
said it could be that sometime in the
fall there'll be some flare-ups we're
going to be in a great position with
everything we've done and everything
we've learned this was something that
nobody ever saw before such contagion
and very very powerful people don't
realize because you we all probably have
friends I have a number of people that
were just great people who were just
decimated by what happened
some were some were some are dead right
now they're dead they went into a
hospital one called me he said they
tested positive four days later he was
dead the following day after he said
that he was unconscious so this is a
tough deal at the same time some people
got sniffles and they didn't even
realize they had a problem and they are
supposedly immune we're gonna find out
about that even that's a little bit soon
because we don't know how long the
immunity lasts but Peter some states are
in great shape and they're really in
great shape to open and I think you'll
have quite a few states opening soon and
they're gonna be very vigilant they're
gonna be very careful
sort of public health what public health
experts have said that this would be
better done if they were comprehensive
surveillance testing which we're
obviously not in position to do I wonder
if maybe dr. Burks and dr. Fox will do
it together
I just wanted it's why I wanted to put
up the syndromic and influenza-like
illness piece because what is key in
this is the early alerts and getting in
there before they even know they have a
problem and I think CDC has been
remarkable in building these platforms
dr. Redfield integrated them so they're
all on the same website if you look at
Co vid 19 you go into cases you can find
all of the data and the beauty of it is
the states are used to utilizing that
through flu season so the testing and
contract tracing and dr. Redfield will
be putting people in every single state
to make sure that CDC is standing beside
the state local health officials to make
sure that all of those cases are
immediately identified and contact trace
I think what's new and what's really
critical is this constant Sentinel
surveillance for asymptomatic
individuals in communities that we know
are particularly vulnerable and that
hasn't been done in flu before and I
think that's going to be the added
dividend that's really focused on who is
most vulnerable and how do we get the
fastest alert by generally screening
people without symptoms so people who
are just coming to the clinic will be
screened for Cova 19:00 and we do have
enough testing capacity to do both that
surveillance piece as well as the
diagnostic piece and contact tracing
actually you know people have gotten
confused about that goes in the
beginning when we were focusing really
on just mitigation and really trying to
keep peaks down and and trying to worry
about ventilators and and ppes and
things like that well now would you get
a little bit more grace period you can
start figuring out what is the
penetrance of this virus in society what
are we missing in people who might be
infected what is the percentage of those
people that are out there that's gonna
inform us greatly for a number of things
including the level once we prove that
antibody test that you have is really
protective and we still don't know that
yet we're going to find that out we may
get a good feel of what the level of
protection might be in society but we
don't know that yet so it's gonna give
us information as to what the vulnerable
areas are and how we need to respond
remember there's two types of things
antibody tests and tests for the
diagnosis of who has the disease one you
need for contact tracing the other you
want to need for finding outlets in
society we're gonna have both of those
much much better as we go in the next
weeks and months and by the time we get
into the fall I think we're going to be
in pretty good shape
as we see a hotspot possibly developing
maybe not but if we see a hotspot
developing we've learned a lot we'll be
able to suppress it wack it will be able
to do things that people weren't even
thinking about because nobody's ever
gone through this in 1917 they went
through something that was similar
probably not as contagious probably more
powerful in certain other ways but we
are going to be able to suppress it we
think and we're going to watch it very
closely we're going to we're going to be
able to watch things very closely please
[Music]
Thank You mr. president
I think what's really important is
during this bringing the people back to
work and our economy back to work and
what's gonna go back is that we're gonna
be very aggressively focused on early
case recognition isolation and contact
tracing in the event that we just went
through unfortunately in as we started
we were very capable of doing that when
the initial cases all came from China
all the way through January all the way
through to the end of February we were
able to identify cases early the first
fourteen do the contacts do the contact
tracing over 800 contacts we identified
that two of those contacts were actually
infected we were able to isolate them we
were able to contain the outbreak we're
about to enter a new phase of this where
we're going back to containment and
mitigation is going to continue as dr.
Burks and others have said some of the
things that we've learned to do we're
going to continue but the the major
thrust of how we're going to control and
make sure that we continue to keep this
nation open is early case recognition
isolation and contact tracing that's the
fundamentals of public health that's
what we're gonna do you see we have very
good surveillance systems that are going
to help us as we see these cases
sporadically across the country we've
got to jump on them with early diagnosis
isolation and contact Tracy and that's
what CDC is going to continue to help
build that capacity in in the states
across this nation we discussed this
today with the Senators where the
Senators we had the congressmen and
women there'll be some areas of our
country wide open plains wide open
spaces with not that many people
relatively speaking where you're not
going to have to do that senators were
saying there is no reason to do that in
certain states in certain areas where
you have the wide open in other cases we
will be doing that so we'll be following
it largely that also will be a function
of governor's they know their states so
largely that's going to be a function of
governor's yesterday you mentioned the
you used to turn clear scientific
benchmarks on testing and the main
periscope that I think you guys are
talking about is the IO IO syndromic as
well as the surveillance and the
Sentinel testing are you opening things
up then without doing I just want to be
clear are you opening things up without
doing widespread testing is that because
you don't have the capacity or you don't
think it's necessary you have the
capacity but you know you have States
without any problem you have States with
few cases and those few cases have
healed you have states with very little
death relatively speaking as I said one
is too many but you have states with
very little and frankly they're at a
point where they have almost nothing so
this is a much different case than a New
York or New Jersey where they're going
through frankly they go through hell and
if you look at New York I'm looking at
bed camp because you have to look at bed
count and its really dropped we built
the Javits Center with 2900 beds and it
was I mean they built it in four days
they did an incredible job the Army
Corps of Engineers it was not used very
much we sent the ship the hospital ship
in to New York Harbor and it was not
used that we went kovat and it still was
not used very much because the bed count
has gone way down way way down this is
this is not campaigning I want to make
the country better I don't care about
campaigning this is this is about making
our country better I think this team has
been incredible whether it's Army Corps
of Engineers whether it's FEMA one thing
that happened on the call today that I
noticed more than anything is Pete
Gaynor so many governors said I want to
thank you Pete Gaynor called up they had
tornadoes in a big part of our country
this weekend this week and they were all
saying that he has been unbelievable
they called one after another they were
thanking us for that's FEMA and they
were thanking us no I want to heal this
country this country is a war we've been
through what we have an invisible as
opposed to a visible enemy I think in
many ways the invisible enemy is much
more dangerous as much tougher in the g7
today I went through a country after
country we were there
we all get along great Angela Merkel and
Shinzo ABI Prime Minister of Japan and
all of them and their their countries
have been devastated by this their
economies have been devastated by this
184 countries all over the world and we
went through one after another and I was
angry because they should have been told
to us it should have been told to us
early it should have been told to us a
lot sooner people knew it was happening
and people didn't want to talk about it
I don't know why but we're gonna get to
the bottom of it but people should have
people so I'm not saying anything I'm
saying people should have told us about
this they should have told the rest of
the world - when I looked at Germany
talking today when I looked at France
talking today the European Union was
there represented that represents a lot
of countries their economies have been
devastated but they're going to build
them back but we're gonna build this
economy back bigger better stronger than
ever before you watch and we have
stimulus and we're gonna do things
whether it's infrastructure which we
would like to be able to do our roads or
tunnels our highways our bridges our
bridges need help you know a lot of you
have reported on our bridges a lot of
bridges are in bad shape they should
have been fixed 25 years ago and they're
still standing they have to be fixed so
hopefully we'll get an infrastructure
bill the good news is the interest rate
is close to zero and zero interest is a
good thing when it comes to rebuilding
your infrastructure in your country back
please in the back mr. president
walk us through the calendar if you
would when it comes to Memorial Day or
even Pentecost in May you've got to July
4th Labor Day weekend what would you
anticipate each of those milestones well
I don't like to anticipate because you
have a couple of states that are in
difficulty that have made a lot of
progress by the way and they're either
here or they're heading down but so I'm
not going to go in in terms of dates but
I think we're going very quickly now I
really believe I think we're gonna have
a lot of states open relatively soon
we're beating the date I said a date of
May first and you know
here we are and I think you're gonna
have some nice surprises over the next
few days and that'll be before and
that's big stuff some of those states
are big they're big stuff very important
states and it's gonna be added on and on
and as we look I don't want anyone
coming back that isn't in position to
come back the last thing we want is for
let's say a New York to come back too
soon or a New Jersey to come back too
soon we want them to come back when
they're ready but they're really heading
in a good direction
and I think it'll be much faster than
people think I think it'll be quicker
but it's got to be safe thank you has
the government modeled the possibility
what would happen how many deaths might
occur if there is a widespread
resurgence if this just doesn't work so
if we didn't do what we did we were
talking about up to 2.2 million deaths
so that's five times almost what we lost
in the Civil War okay if everything
happens properly and if we continue to
go the way we're going now we will be
significantly less than the lowest
number with mitigation so we'll be
significantly less and it's still a lot
of people one is too many as I've said
one is too many but we'll be under the
number of 100,000 which was the minimum
number projected by the model and I give
I give everybody up here I give all of
the people that we've been we this was a
military operation with a lot of private
help if you look at Roche they were
incredible look at Johnson and Johnson
now what they're doing they are very far
advanced on a vaccine I think
therapeutically we have some of these
genius companies they're truly genius
companies I'm seeing I'm I'm meeting
with the people that run the companies
and scientists and I mean what they're
doing is incredible it's incredible it's
a beautiful thing to see so I think
we're very far advanced and I think
we're gonna be in great shape
soon yep
president I really don't want to mention
specific states but what about
Washington and California to have
guidance
you mean Washington State or Washington
here well that's going to be up to them
they're gonna have to make that
determination I mean the governor of
Washington was saying that he can't find
cotton because you know a swab is a very
easy thing to get and swab is
essentially it's a little bit more
sophisticated than a q-tip and you got
to be able to go out and find you know
the federal government shouldn't be
forced to go and do everything what
we've done is incredible well we've done
are the the ones that can't be done like
for instance the ventilators that can't
be done by anybody but a very powerful
very great manufacturing country which
is what we are and what we're really
getting to be and I have to tell you
some of these companies what the job
they've done are we're going to
recognize them pretty soon the job
they've done in terms of getting out in
particular Ventura is because
ventilators are so hard there so I say
and some people say oh it's not really
as complicated well it's like building a
car and you know what the price is the
same - it's a very expensive thing for a
sophisticated ventilator it's very very
tough stuff yep it is mr. president let
me go talk to this question up to you
and to the doctors as well truthfully
for those states that aren't ready to go
to phase one to get through these phases
do we have an idea of how many millions
tens of millions of tests they're going
to need for them to get through these
phases any number out there tests of any
sort yeah so I mean I you've heard me
talk about tests for a while from the
podium and I think what has happened
over the last several weeks is hospitals
and and clinics that could move to the
more point-of-care tests move to those
point-of-care tests and what it's left
is an amazing array of capacity that
exists in the country for at least a
million more tests per week so we have a
whole team we're
lab by lab to see what it would take to
turn on all of those labs that aren't
running the pieces of equipment now so
you see in the system I just said to you
there's a million more tests per week
that we have tests sitting there and
equipment sitting there and now we have
to really deal with each single lab to
really figure out what they need and I
just want to thank administrator Verma
Seema Verma who went through with us and
thanks to the lab directors they really
explained to us highly technical
difficulty to run some of these big
pieces of equipment because you have to
Alec caught the samples you have to
centrifuge you have to put them on the
machine takes a tech full-time at 50
dollars a test it wasn't enough to hire
another technician to run the machine
full-time so a hundred dollars a test it
is so those the kinds of changes we have
to make bit by bit by bit but that alone
doubles our testing capacity per week so
we're committed to work with
laboratories to answer every one of
their issues with the state and local
governments and I think frankly every
conversation I have and the governor's
will say I need five thousand people
tested and I say well at the University
of X there are 67 hundred tests waiting
for you so it's more of making sure that
every governor and every public health
official knows exactly where every lab
is and where the tests are so we can
create with them a real understanding so
all these tests can be run so yes there
is twice the capacity right now just so
you understand we have tremendous cake
testing capacity you look at the labs
they're actually saying send us and the
reason it's gone down is because we have
so many other tests that frankly are
easier because you don't have to send
there on-site and now we have the new
saliva test that just came out yesterday
which is probably the easiest of them
all when you get right down to it and I
was seeing where Rutgers is involved
great school great college great
University
and they're using that so many people
are going to want to use that but they
don't have to use the
labs that Hema labs are great highly
accurate very very great companies but
they're down they have tremendous as as
that goes down you have additional
capacity we have tremendous testing
capacity and to think that a month and a
half ago we had virtually nothing I just
want to conclude we're opening up our
great country again it's going to be
over a period of time we're working with
some really great people people that
have become friends of mine and I'm I'm
including Democrat governor's that have
really done a good job
Republican governors most of whom I've
known that have done a really good job
they're all working together we're all
for that with few exceptions the
relationship has been outstanding and I
want to thank dr. dr. and Mike I want to
thank the director fantastic job
we've all done by the way head of the
FDA he has broken hurdles that years ago
even recently would have taken years he
was he got one thing done in one day
that would have taken two years for
somebody else so I want to thank dr.
Hahn of the FDA we have incredible
people that we're working with and we're
gonna bring our country back and it's
going to be bigger and better and
stronger than ever before we have
learned a lot we've learned a lot about
ourselves and I want to thank everybody
and most importantly